a professor at the University of
Maryland asked this
awesomely evil test question you have
the opportunity to earn extra points for
this exam
select whether you want two points or
six points
but there's a small catch if more than
10 percent in the class pick six points
then no one will get any points only I
will see your selection it will be
anonymous to the rest of the class
do you pick two points or six points? when
this question was
posted to Twitter it went viral with a
lot of people discussing the question
it looks like there's a dilemma here and a
lot of people thought that
look if we at least pick two points
everyone can cooperate then at least we
can get two
but that's not the game theory way to
think about this question
so let's try and to analyze what the
correct strategic decision
should be given the incentives of this
question
you want to think about your choice
relative to what the other people in the
class are doing
and the relevant characteristic is how
many people
are picking 6 it could be that more than
10 percent in the class is picking 6
it could be the case that fewer than 10
percent in the class is picking six
or there's a small probability that
may be exactly 10 percent of the other
people are picking 6
we'll construct a matrix based on what
the other people are doing
to see what your payoff will be if more
than 10 percent in the class
is picking 6 then it doesn't matter
whether you pick two or six
everyone is going to get zero points
now, if fewer than 10 percent to the other
people are picking six
say everyone else is picking two then
you are going to get the number points
that you pick
if you pick two points you get two, if
you pick six points you get six
and now you can see something very
interesting you are
always better off at least as good of
picking 6
as if you are picking two so picking six
here
is a logical choice whether the class is
more than 10 percent picking 6
or less than 10 percent
picking 6 you are always going to score
more points if you pick 6
versus 2 now there's one
third case to consider that may be
exactly 10 percent pick 6
in this case you would get two if you
picked two
but you would ruin it for everyone and
get zero
if you pick 6 you would, you know, increase
the threshold beyond 10 percent
so in this one small scenario
you're actually better off picking two
points but is kinda
rare and there's no way you can know
that exactly 10 percent in the class
is picking 6 so in a class of ten that
would be
exactly one person picking 6 and
everyone else
picking two this is a very unlikely
scenario
so you can kinda disregard this third
possibility and you could say picking 6
is the logical thing to do
but there's another reason to think
about why picking six is logical
exams are not usually based on the
absolute number of points you get
it's not usually a point threshold that
ninety percent is in a eighty percent is a B
that's usually true in grade school or
high school but once you get to college
everything is usually graded on a curve
your grade
is based on how much better you do
relative to everyone else
so you don't want to think about the
absolute number of points you're getting
you want to think about how many more
points you're getting than other people
so when you think in this relativistic
method
if you get 2 and everyone else gets
2 your getting zero extra points
whereas if you get six and other people
get 2
then you have a chance to get four extra
points so we want to reduce the payouts
when points are awarded by two
so if the class is getting more than 10
percent's picking 6 no one's getting
points anyway
if you fewer than 10 percent are
picking 6
then when you pick two if everyone gets two,
you're not getting any more points than
anyone else who's picking 2
but if you get six and other people are
getting two you get four extra points
and then look at the third scenario where
exactly 10 percent is picking six
so say one in 10
out of your ten percent class is picking
six and
one person's picking six and every one else is picking two
then you're not going to do any better
than the people who are picking two
and if you pick six and spoil it for
everyone then you
get zero so when you look at the payouts
now
picking six is always at least as good
as picking two
so in this case picking 6 is the logical
choice
and it's what's known as a weakly
dominant strategy so when you have a
weakly dominant strategy you're gonna
wanna play it
now the unfortunate outcome even though
everyone individually is thinking about
picking six and they all pick six
you end in a situation that everyone ends up
with zero points
but this is not because any individual
person is thinking wrong
this game is sorta rigged so that the
group outcome sorta says oh you pick 6
you're selfish
but that's not really the case I think
it should be your decision to pick six
and that's the logical thing to do
thanks for watching this video
if you like more videos about game
theory and math please subscribe to my
channel
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and Petron
you can also catch me on social media at
Presh Talwalker
and if you like this video please check
out my books I've written a book about
game theory an introduction to strategic
thinking
which will help you understand this
example and many more ways to use
math to
outsmart your opponents